[Music]
kids are savage but we found some
parents who definitely have a better
sense of humor than their kids from
birthday presents to text messages get
ready to be jealous over these kids
awesome parents give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button to
never miss another video again now let's
check out 20 parents to sense of humor
is better than their kids Marilyn
Manson's dad let's start with famous
dads Marilyn Manson is one of those most
controversial musicians but his dad
doesn't seem to care that his son is an
idol to many it seems like even
celebrity parents like to joke around
and embarrass their kids Hugh Horner
Marilyn Manson's dad dressed up like his
son and did a photo shoot it turns out
his behavior was pretty embarrassing for
Marilyn however we think his dad
definitely has a better sense of humor
than its kid and he looks pretty awesome
with Marilyn's makeup wait until you see
some other savage parents who really
went all in with their twisted sense of
humor snapchat dad some kids have at
least one parent that wants to be the
cool one and follow their kids on social
media sometimes that can easily backfire
for everyone involved like this dad for
example he either has no idea how
snapchat filters work or he's just
mocking this generations obsession with
changing the way they look he received a
picture from his daughter with the
flower snapchat filter on and like a
true dad he took it to the next level
and made his own real-life flower filter
we have to say he looks pretty awesome
even though the dad himself doesn't look
like he's impressed by what he's done
April Fool's Day imagine getting a text
message that says you've got $10,000
deposited to your account this ferret
knew their kids would read the text with
an open mouth while trying to gasp for
air they created this hilarious text
message informing the kid of a fake
$10,000 transfer and then added that
they should close their mouths and click
gaping at the screen because it's April
Fool's Day we have to admit that we
thought it was pretty real until we got
to the end this parent really knows how
to pull off a good prank but we do feel
kind of bad for the recipients of this
message dad facts sometimes parenting
takes an unexpected turn it seems like
this dad lost all hope when he presented
this sad fact to his child he wrote that
every
the kid doesn't eat their sandwich a
unicorn dies talking about traumatizing
a kid if this was us we'd make sure we'd
eat every sandwich there is and then
some just so we can keep all unicorns
alive the best part of this message was
definitely the dad's clever use of
hashtags seems like this dad doesn't
really belong to the old-school cool
Club with his awesome jokes and hashtags
and don't forget to eat your food and
save a unicorn Wi-Fi password this
parent knows how to make their kids do
the chores talk about modern parenting
sometimes you just need to force your
kids to stop being on their laptops and
phones by taking away what matters the
most limiting the Wi-Fi usage can be
difficult for this parent had the right
idea this is how modern parents make
their kids do the chores just change the
password and don't give it back until
the kids do the chores like make the bed
vacuum the carpet and walk the dog we
bet everything would be done as fast as
possible this parent definitely has the
best interviewer although we're pretty
sure the child doesn't think so
selfie dad we've already seen the
snapchat dad but he's definitely not the
only cool parent around parents are
known to mock kids for their modern ways
like taking thousands of selfies this
dad has had enough and decided to take
his sweet time and impressively redo his
daughter's selfies he imitated
everything from her hair and septum
piercing to her clothes and even tattoos
he even pasted the same decor on the
wall he really went all in just to
recreate her selfie check out those
impressive fake tattoos looks like this
dad really knows how to make fun of his
kids and we're all here for it whoo way
to go dad get along siblings will fight
no matter how much you tell them that
they shouldn't but modern parenting also
figured out new ways to make kids get
along we're not sure if this works but
it definitely looks hilarious
this parent decided they had enough of
their kids constantly fighting so they
put them in the same shirt and made them
talk it out what's even funnier is that
according to the text they always use
the exact same shirt and these kids
really don't look happy about it what do
you think does this parenting method
actually work or are siblings just a
hopeless case when it comes to fighting
oMG this dad tried to be cool with the
kids
it's
that you see parents use internet slang
in the correct way but he seems to have
it figured out it looks like he's trying
to make fun of his kid who asked if
he'll come and get them the dad just
kept on replying with oMG over and over
again until his kid had enough and said
they'll tell on him to their mom to stay
in character all the dad replied was oMG
no absolutely amazing text exchange and
one of our favorites were showing you
today
wait until you see our top ten parents
with the best sense of humor get ready
to giggle first driving lesson kids
growing up scares just about any parent
and sometimes they have to prepare
themselves and let them become adults
like this dad who took his daughter's
driving lessons very seriously and came
totally prepared for any kinds of impact
check out what he's actually wearing he
put on a helmet and a life jacket to
show his daughter exactly what he thinks
about her first driving lesson and by
the looks of it his daughter looks
pretty embarrassed that's definitely
another parent with an amazing sense of
humor we're pretty sure they were both
safe during the entire lesson although
we're not sure how comfortable the dad
was in his outfit kitchen most parents
were a card to keep their house clean
and most of the time the kids don't help
out at all this mom didn't ask the kids
to help out though she just wanted them
to keep the kitchen clean which is
probably a much harder job having and
Molly found this note which said they
have to keep the kitchen clean with the
way they found it and if they don't
their own mother will punch them in the
throat it might be aggressive but we
have a feeling this note definitely
worked and the kitchen was left clean
for a long time just make sure your note
isn't too violent and you're good to go
1 million likes this parenting lesson is
different than most begging for likes in
order to convince your parents to give
you what you wanted used to be a popular
social media trend but the trend
definitely didn't work for these kids
this mom gave her kids a note that
stated they won't get anything for their
1 million likes because they have to
work for the things they want not beg
for them on Facebook she definitely has
the right idea and probably a better
sense of humor than a lot of kids who
did beg for likes on social media way to
go mom this funny dad we're on to some
of our absolute favorite moments of
hilarious
parenting we're pretty sure this dad is
somehow connected with the
second-to-last moment on our list check
out this hilarious moment we have no
idea of this dad has awesome photoshop
skills or if he just randomly found a
deer and put it in his car but this is a
pretty funny image it gets even better
when you read the caption this dad might
be the funniest person to himself but we
definitely think he's pretty funny too
which is why he's on our list in the
first place
wait until you see another version of
this joke in just a few moments but
first check out some of our favorite
parenting moments rescue dog some
parents love to overshare especially in
text messages this dad met his
daughter's new rescue dog and he seems
to be totally traumatized by the size of
the dog's intimate parts in a funny text
exchange he says he never wants to sit
on her couch again because of the size
of the dog's private area his child is
clearly clueless and has no idea what's
happening and then the dad says that if
they end up going to his daughter's
house they should definitely bring
Febreze dads don't hold back when it
comes to having opinions on something
they don't like to be fair we have no
clue hug reply to this text either cool
mom but it's not just - that want to be
cool this mom has a better sense of
humor than her kids with this hilarious
text message exchange she texted her kid
the usual good morning message but she
added bra at the end which is definitely
something parents don't say the kid
tells her to stop stay in bra which
means she has probably done this in more
than once she hilariously replies that
she says bra because it's cool and she's
a cool mom we wonder if she still calls
her kids bra or if she's over her cool
mom face after realizing no one even
says that word anymore 5-million this
mom is total savage some kids get
whatever they want for their birthday
including cash but this mom had a
different idea her kid asked for five
million dollars for his birthday and his
mom decided to pull a little prank on
him instead of giving him the money
she bought a stack of 100 grands fun
sized chocolate bars and we have a
feeling these 100 grands add up to 5
million well-played mom if her son loves
chocolate we have a feeling he wouldn't
mind this present anyways we're sure we
would love to get a bunch of 100 grands
for our birthday
obsessed sometimes parents just need to
take a break from their kids this mom
clearly hates her children messaging her
constantly probably asking her to do
something when her child was trying to
reach her and get her to reply by
repeatedly writing mom she wasn't having
any of it this is definitely a modern
mom because very rarely will you see a
parent reply with a gift but she clearly
knows what she's doing
she sends her kid a mean girls gift
asking them why they're so obsessed with
her absolutely hilarious and we bet the
kid was totally speechless after this
funny moment well done mom painted house
now these are the parents that have a
perfect sense of humor while their child
was away they decided to paint their
house but by the looks of it they left a
little present for their kid they
painted the word dork on the wall and
pointed to the room where the kid was
staying at we have no idea how long they
left this on without repainting it but
this is absolutely hilarious and one of
our favorite funny parenting moments of
all time well of course right after the
final three moments that just make us
giggle every time we see these pictures
here are the best parenting moments ever
gold-digger we all know that some kids
only contact their parents when they
want something and it usually involves
money being suddenly nice to your
parents is a universal sign of wanting
something this dad definitely knew what
was up when he received an overly polite
message from his child and it looks like
he didn't hold back when he replied with
asking them what's up and called them
his little golddigger
a shocking behavior for most but we
think this dad definitely has a sense of
humor that's a lot better than his
child's calling your child a gold digger
will never not be funny because let's be
honest it's definitely true for some
kids good luck parents with a sense of
humor are the best but what's even
better is a dad upgrading from regular
dad jokes this is one of the best dad
joke upgrades we have ever seen Kelsi
hit a deer with her car the day before
and this dad thought he'd make the
situation even more inappropriate he
sends her a picture of a deer and wished
her luck on her AP exam and that he
knows she'll do good but he used a
different word do you get what he meant
in all honesty we hope the deer she hit
was actually okay and that her AP exam
ended up going well even though her
father's message
was uncalled for range ah but our
absolute favorite funny parenting moment
of all time is this dad we took dad puns
to a new level
he must be listening to modern music
because his lyrics are definitely on
point he surprised is done with a
present that looks like a MacBook Pro
but when he opened the box he got a
picture of my goes with the lyrics rain
drop drop top ha you thought you got a
laptop we're pretty sure the kid was
completely disappointed but we're
actually impressed by this dad's rhyming
skills
well played dad well played what's the
funniest thing your parents have ever
done let us know in the comments and
that's it for our video for more videos
like this one check out 20 toys no kid
wants to receive on their birthday see
you next time
[Music]